You fought all year,
beat out scandal after scandal,
got your husband
to keep his dick in his pants--
though, that was probably
largely because of his age--
and finally
reached the big night
where you're officially
nominated
as the Democratic
presidential candidate.
What better way to celebrate
than with a kick-ass video?
Jack, roll the kick-assness!
♪
(glass shattering)
-(laughter)
-Oh, God.
(laughter)
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Rise to the top
and destroy all of your haters!
(laughter)
As with most videos released on
the Internet, this got a remix.
Comedians,
what was the video mashed-up
with Stone Cold Steve Austin's
theme song,
-or the Imperial March from...?
Yes, Matt Mira. -It's...
I mean, it's got to be
Stone Cold. The glass shatters.
-You're thinking Hillary 3:16.
-All right, let's find out.
(glass shatters)
-♪
-OTHERS: Yeah!
HAHN:
Yes!
Hillary 3:16 says
I don't understand e-mail!
(laughter)
How awesome, though.
She smashed the ceiling
but cracked a smile.
-(laughter)
-She did.